[Music]
netflix the reigning champion of all
streaming sites is still many people's
go-to when looking for a new film to
watch whether you want a classic
favorite or a hot new release the
streaming giant has no shortage of
movies for film aficionados to enjoy
this holds especially true for horror
fans for many netflix is the best place
for horror this side of shutter netflix
often snags the distribution rights to
some remarkable scary films giving
audiences plenty of options when they
are in search of a fright we're not even
into october yet and the service has
already provided some of the most
chilling films of the year already with
the fear street trilogy and army of the
dead the latest film to keep you up at
night is 2020's the old ways and the
suspenseful film has audiences on the
edge of their seats the film follows
christina lopez a mexican-american
journalist who returns to her hometown
near veracruz to research a story on
witchcraft there she is kidnapped by a
group of locals including a bruja which
means witch in english who thinks she's
possessed by a demon all the familiar
beats of a classic demon possession
movie are there but with some sly twists
the film manages to embed itself within
your mind you can watch the trailer to
see if it's up your alley as you witness
christina fighting for her life and
struggling to know what's real right
from the opening scene you know you're
in for a terrifying time we get the
chance to see an exorcism in action and
immediately after that we see a woman
with a bag over her head you wind up
being just as confused and terrified as
christina and that's when the big
revelation takes place her cousin
miranda and some of the townsfolk want
to keep her restrained until they have
an opportunity to remove the demon
inside of her christina may abide by
modern sensibilities but in this town
they adhere to the old ways the movie
scored a fairly impressive 100 tomato
meter rating on rotten tomatoes michelle
swope of dread central praises the film
for its wicked practical effects and how
it uses body horror as a way to
represent christina's inner demons and
her refusal to deal with them over at
the upcoming andrew murray calls it a
highly entertaining new spin on the
exorcism genre the old ways is more than
just your average horror film though the
film explores complex themes such as
diction feeling like a stranger in your
hometown and loss of culture the movie
also highlights the unshakable bond of
family in particular cat hughes of the
hollywood news remarks on the film's
exploration of the relationship between
the captured christina and her estranged
cousin saying watching these women
attempt to reconnect especially under
extreme conditions adds a necessary
layer of warmth to what could be just
another heartless and cold horror the
perfect mix of body horror exorcism
family drama and thrilling suspense the
old ways is a must watch now streaming
on netflix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
hidden horror gems are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one